Hello everyone, this is Ann, practitioner and genetic specialist here at Conner's Clinic.
And in this video, we are going to talk about iron and the phantom reaction and the genes
in your genetic report that are related to this.
So, when we're talking about iron, we're talking about the mineral that is necessary for proper
bodily function, important in many things that we need for a healthy body.
So iron is involved in the production of heme, which then in turn is involved in producing
hemoglobin.
And hemoglobin is the molecule within the red blood cell that carries oxygen from the
lungs and delivers it throughout the body.
So we can see right here, it's talking about the iron, the health benefits of iron.
We see the formation of red blood cells.
So the red blood cells, again, they have to contain hemoglobin and hemoglobin is what
carries oxygen throughout the body.
So we need, obviously, to have oxygen throughout the body.
It is important for cognitive function, important for strong immunity.
Iron is going to help prevent anemia.
So anemia is low iron, low iron conditions where all of these things are not happening
properly because we have low iron.
It's involved in energy production and really the ability to use our muscles.
If we have anemia, we have low iron, we have brain fog, we can have fatigue, we can have
really sore muscles, it's just hard to move.
And then iron is also involved in helping maintain a good mood.
So iron is very important for health.
And we have to get iron from dietary sources.
And so here is an image that's just listing some of the dietary sources of iron, plant-based
sources, and then animal-based sources.
And really there is a difference between animal and plant-based iron.
So animal sources are going to contain that hem iron that is better absorbed and utilized
than plant-based sources of iron.
And it's abundant in leafy greens.
Red meat chicken has some broccoli, spinach is high in iron, pumpkin seeds.
So lots of different foods have a great source of iron, right?
And then we need to talk a little bit about the different forms of iron.
So there is bound iron and there is free iron.
And iron is when the iron is bound to a molecule that is kind of keeping it from being in a chemical
state where it is reactive.
So an example of bound iron would be the hemoglobin.
So iron is bound to that hemoglobin within the blood, so it's not chemically reactive.
And then another example would be ferritin.
So within the cells, ferritin is holding onto that iron.
So when it's bound, it's being held until the body needs to utilize those sources.
So that is the proper way we want to have iron within the body.
It's bound to these protein molecules and then when we need it, it is facilitated and
then used appropriately.
And if that is not happening, then we can have free iron.
So free iron is unbound and can be, that's where it can be reactive, chemically reactive.
And it can be damaging to the body, especially if it is in excess.
If we have excess amounts of this unbound iron, it can create damage.
Short term, you know, your body has checks and balances to keep that in check.
Keep it in place from the damage getting out of control, but long term, if we have an excess
amount of this free iron, it really can lead to damage to the cells, damage to tissue and
damage to organs.
And so we have up here on the screen, kind of an example, a visual example of what happens
if we have, you know, this free iron that's causing this stress or oxidative stress within
the body.
So, you know, you slice an apple, you know, and you've eaten some of the apple, you walk
away and you come back an hour later to finish up that apple and what happens?
Well, the apple has turned brown.
That is oxidation and that is essentially what happens if we have that free iron, unbound
iron within the body, creates that oxidative stress and really kind of damages things that
it comes in contact with.
So this is just a little visual example of oxidation.
All right, and here are some examples of causes of excess iron.
So, you know, as we're talking about genes, we can have genetic predispositions, variants
in our genes that, you know, kind of give us a predisposition for excess unbound
iron.
So the damaging effects of this iron, and we'll talk about some of those, alcohol consumption
can increase iron absorption, excessive red meat consumption, cooking in cast iron skillets.
So when we're, you know, warming up our cast iron skillets and cooking food, some of the
iron can leach into the food, especially acidic foods like tomatoes, so we need to be careful
of that.
If we have a predisposition for this, and then there's foods that process foods that are
fortified with iron, and a little note here that says this form of iron is inorganic and
can be much more dangerous than iron that is naturally occurring in foods.
So really we don't want to be eating a lot of packaged foods obviously in the first place.
And certainly we don't really want foods that are fortified with inorganic iron.
Supplements obviously can contain iron, so it's good to know, good to look at these genes
and see, okay, do I have a predisposition for improper facilitation of this iron and potential
inflammation or damage from excess iron?
So we wouldn't want to be supplementing with iron.
And then it's also important to know what form of your iron supplement to are taking
because there's some good forms and bad forms that we want to watch out for.
Iron synergists that can increase absorption, so an example of this would be vitamin C.
So vitamin C increases the absorption of iron, so if you're eating red meat and, you know,
you're drinking a big old glass of orange juice or something that vitamin C from the orange
juice is going to allow for excess absorption or more absorption of that iron from the red meat,
so something to be aware of.
And then hepatitis or abdominal injuries can, you know, create some excess iron as well.
All right, so when we're looking at genes involved in iron regulation within the body, these
are some of the ones that we're looking at within your report.
HF, the HFE gene is really a gene that is involved with a diagnosis of hemacromatosis.
So that is an iron overload condition so that, you know, excess absorption of iron can create
excess free iron, so we want to watch for that.
And then we have these are genes that are involved in, so this would be the HFE gene would
really be excess free iron within the blood.
And then these genes here are kind of relating to ferritin, so variants here can increase absorption
of iron into the cells, and we need to watch for that.
This gene here is the only gene, the SLC for 0A1, is the only gene that exports iron from
the cells.
We have a number of ways that iron can get into the cell, but we've only got one exporter
out of the cell, and so if we have variants here, then it can lead to too much iron within
the cell, which is obviously something that we need to be careful of.
And then this last gene listed here, this CP gene that creates seruloplasm, this is necessary
for healthy use of iron, and production of seruloplasm is dependent on vitamin A.
And so when we know that, then we also need to look at, oh, we have a gene that is involved
in vitamin A, the conversion of beta-carotene into the active form of vitamin A, that's the
BCMO1 gene.
So, if we have issues in the BCMO1 gene, that can also affect this CP gene as far as seruloplasm,
and then its involvement with healthy use of iron as well.
All right, and we have this nice graphic here from Nutrogenetic Research Institute, so this
is where, you know, the certification course that we went through our practitioners here
at Conner's Clinic, so this is the training course that we did.
And so this is just, you know, one of the ways that excess iron can, you know, negatively
be used to create some of these damaging things and inflammation.
So, this here represents the superoxide free radical, which is a free radical, that is,
you know, it's the most abundant free radical within the body, it's produced by normal metabolic
functioning of your cells, but we have other genes in place to neutralize this.
So again, that checks and balances, so your body is going to create some superoxide, and then
we have this SOD gene here, this gene is the superoxide, dismutease gene, so it's going
to take that superoxide and convert it into hydrogen peroxide.
And this hydrogen peroxide needs to go another step further to be neutralized.
We need the catalyst gene, some other genes are involved as well.
Ultimately, we're at a neutral point with water and oxygen, so that is desired when we have
this excess free iron, this unbound iron, the hydrogen peroxide can bind with iron, and
this, the two together can create these hydroxyl free radicals, and this is what is contributing
to that oxidative stress that is damaging cells, tissues, and organs.
And when we have production of this, if we have excess production, it then, you know, triggers
other genetic pathways to kind of try to balance that, but in the process can create some
other damaging oxidative, you know, things here, this peroxia nitrite is oxidative as well,
can contribute to cardiovascular issues, and lots of, you know, kind of tissue damage, you
know, pain that might migrate from one place to the other, you can't quite pinpoint, can
be due to excess peroxia nitrite.
So this hydroxyl free radical can stimulate your NOS gene, that's nitric oxide synthase,
that produces nitric oxide, and excess nitric oxide is not good either, so if we have excess
hydroxyl free radicals, we could be ending up creating excess nitric oxide, and then we can
be creating peroxia nitrite, so lots of negative things can happen when, when things are
out of balance, so that is the beauty and the value of looking at these genetic pathways
to see where we might have some of these weaknesses, so we can correct these things from a genetic,
you know, molecular level, so everything can work properly, and we're not going to run
into conditions down the road, so it's good to look at these genetic pathways.
So hopefully this helps you gain some understanding about iron, the benefits of iron, but then
also the negatives, if there's excess iron, and, you know, the inflammation that can develop
if you have some excess iron, all right, well thank you for listening.